in the home
Los Angeles
is screen junkies movie fines
Andi signor today's episode is brought
to you by America's best unlimited
network don't miss a show with unlimited
data from t-mobile
hello screen junkies and welcome to
another episode of movie fights live
here on YouTube every Thursday 4 p.m.
and we have a great show for you because
we have some great guests so we're gonna
be talking about who should direct Star
Wars Episode nine obviously that the big
news this week along with what's the
worst Stephen King adaptation it is
doing so well let's talk about some of
the stinkers and the rumor is that mutt
Williams is not coming back and into the
world of Indiana Jones so we want to ask
who should be Indiana Jones's new
sidekick they will be pitching new ones
as along with some other fun topics so
don't forget to tune in and watch on
Twitter along with the fight if you're
watching us live at hashtag move fights
live tell us what you want to answer or
in the comments below and Dan Morelle on
the couch we'll be following all that
madness as the comments go by quickly
and I'm higher hey Dan I'm so confused I
have nothing with my headphones and I
don't go with my camera zone so how are
you I'm just here I'm on camera always
this is my con all right good good
that's fine I can hear you in the room
good here but hey as long as the people
at home they'll tell you in the comments
that's yes they'll tells you sway exact
I danced to me good fight though have a
great fight love this panel yeah love
these questions to fun things and debut
ER that I'd the fans would be very
excited about let's introduce some first
up he's an actor and writer it's been
Begley welcome back hey everybody it has
been my favorite part so far about the
show has been trying to figure out when
to react and when to just have a poker
face sitting next to you it's just
sitting you're like in the inter like oh
I'm in it don't react maybe react I
don't know but hey I'm hard to go back
and watch what you didn't tell me to up
turning the comments up been dead sure
there are it's great
well Ben I'm happy to have you back you
did you played great last time I need
fun this time and yours fan which is
important this week so we'll see how you
do
next up I'm so happy to have her back
all over YouTube twitch and the rest of
the internet it's Trisha Hershberger I'm
super stoked to be here this week
especially since we're arguing Star Wars
this is gonna be really really fun and
this is my first time doing this live
everywhere not just on sj+ which is
really cool
yes Congrats for coming back and Kratz
on the new the new one I'm very excited
for baby fights we all created something
that actually matters
no it really does and I've learned
anyway welcome and congrats Trisha so
happy to have you back next up finally
making his movie fights debut he came
all the way from Down Under youtuber
podcaster James Clements owned a no
you're not seeing a go face meter
because when I look at a mirror I see a
goat face so yeah this is everybody else
ya know people get to hear you mostly I
don't guess I mean fans the face was
revealed to your fans to see you like
the gorillas your face is only revealed
everyone well fancy we've been working
this for years ready but I thank you for
finally coming down here and time in the
sand we're so happy to have you are you
nervous you excited I mean cuz I didn't
normally do camera stuff and I don't do
a lot of stuff and you know I have like
a weird forehead so all those things
kind of they can pound and then you have
to you know sit here and have you ever
done something for 90 minutes with just
you live talking on video I actually
like we did like a fan kind of event
okay so there should be another one
where people who just are used to
hearing your voice from like wow yeah
exactly my forehead fights though
landing strip size
one two and it just gets shinier as the
show goes yeah we're all gonna be an oil
slick
all right let's get to it you guys know
how this works and James pretty as a
newbie here scoring is based on
creativity facts passion basically you
got to win the argument don't give up
even if you're feeling half way through
that you're losing keep fighting and
that's how this show will work all right
let's do it
Harry Lee also from Australia made that
for us oh really I always loved that
Australia right exactly alright let's
get to the fight that everyone clicked
here for the one that matters this one
comes in from we're starting with debate
with the biggie mr. Maxwell demon on
Twitter also suggested this along with
so many people because once the news
broke we knew this was our title fight
this week guys Colin Trevorrow is no
longer directing episode 9 many of us
were not shocked I think some people
were now just figuring out who are they
gonna get the obvious answers are JJ or
Ryan Johnson let's not do the obvious
answers if you could pick any director
aside from the ones already in the
stable that made probably take this over
who we want to see direct Star Wars
Episode nine Ben you're up first alright
this is probably an obvious one for me
it was I think Steven Spielberg would be
amazing because he has a track record of
some of the best adventure films of all
time and in my opinion perfect adventure
films like Raiders of the Lost Ark and
he also has a mastery of combining
digital and special visual effects back
with Jurassic Park so I would love to
see what he could do with that
technology now and yeah I just think
that I think he also would play nice
because him and Kathleen Kennedy have a
history together and I think that bad
pretty likely he wouldn't be fired so he
has a track record that's amazing Trisha
who are you picking I would love to see
patty Jenkins direct episode 9 she's
proven that she can obviously handle a
major epic studio film and she's done
more than just Wonder Woman I mean for
God's sake anyone who's seen monster can
just talk about how amazing that was and
the performance that was brought out of
Charlize Theron in that oscar-winning
performance she's proven she can do tons
of action there were amazing action
sequences in fact I I might say arguably
the best action sequence ever in that
original famous Karen battle scene in
Wonder Woman and I would love to see her
wrap up Ray's story in a way that does
that character justice and in much the
same way that many little kids all
around the world right now wanna be
Wonder Woman because of what she's done
with the character of Diana Prince I
want to see many many little kids even
more than there are now wanna be ray
alright James who are you pickin good
stuff for me it's Matthew Vaughn is the
really obvious choice for
reasons firstly every movie that he's
tackled every genre that he's tackled
he's nailed he started with like a
gritty kind of British crime thriller
layer cake which is amazing with Daniel
Craig after that he did start us which
is this Princess Bride
ass kind of adventure film and he made
this film that I would say right it's
not as good as Princess Bride but it
rivals the kind of feel of that movie
and hasn't really been anything else
like that since Princess Bride and then
after that of course he did I'm not sure
on this order but he did first-class he
stepped into the x-men franchise very
late in the game like way too late for
somebody to pull off anything good I
think he turned down x-men 3 because it
was too late and then he said yes to
x-men first class on an even shorter
schedule and he made one of the best
x-men films in my opinion that rescue
the franchise alright so guys tell me
why yours is better than the others
fight it out alright I would argue that
patty Jenkins as even though Wonder
Woman was one of my favorite films of
the year I think there's two problems I
had with Wonder Woman was that the
villains weren't very clearly defined
and if you can tell me anything about
dr. death except that she's just let
free in the end that bothered me a lot I
think the villains are just as important
as Ray's story I do agree she would nail
Ray's story but there's more to episode
9 than just ray and I also think that
the CGI and the third act of Wonder
Woman got very bombastic and kind of
Batman V Superman crazy so I haven't
seen yet that she can handle CGI as well
as Steven Spielberg and the practical
practical effects that he would bring to
it as well as Matthew Vaughn I think his
best films are the crazy ones where he
can get super stylish and out there with
it like kick-ass and Kingsman and I feel
like he would get fired very quickly
like Lord and Miller because he does his
own thing and clearly that's not what
Star Wars once they want their template
spielberg plays within that template
just like Ron Howard JJ and Lucas back
back in the day I'm not worried about
patty Jenkins needing to establish
villains I think the villains in this
trilogy are already very clearly
established and I'm also not worried
about the lack of CGI because let's just
go practical everybody wants to see
practical right now anyway and we've
seen that done really really well
again we're also basing villains
specifically on Wonder Woman and if you
look at the other films that patty
Jenkins done I don't think that that's
something that you can specifically
attack when it comes to Steven Spielberg
as
option however my biggest problem with
that would be that he said he's never
going to direct a Star Wars I want
someone who wants to direct a Star Wars
he's one of Lucas's very best friends he
said Lucas won't let him do it and he
respects that and he has actually said
the quote I'm never going to make a Star
Wars film so that for me takes him right
out of the running sure when you can so
one of them that's a good film I
wouldn't say it's a great film I'd say
it's a great female superhero film
because we literally haven't had any
other good ones aside from that but the
third act of Wonder Woman is the same as
every other DC current movie where is
where where as in there's a big gray
monster and there's a lot of smoke and
CGI find they just kind of fly to each
other and it's just nothing like it's a
nothing saying and I she did do a good
like some good action sequences in that
film including the trench in the bit
where she runs in and flips the tank
like it's a bloody a smaller tank but
but I just think that she doesn't have
been created with the actions
creativeness of the action sequences
that Matthew Vaughn does when you look
at kick-ass the end of kick-ass not
picking out sorry the end of Kingsman is
the song baby give it up and it's a
woman with blades four legs kicking the
[ __ ] out of a spy who kills her by
kicking her with a poison blade and I
think that's incredible
also Spielberg's boring hasn't made an
interesting action I think he's done
amazing films but he would have make the
bill make the bland a Star Wars film of
all time it would probably be fine and
you know all paint by numbers and
whatever but crystal skull is not good I
was gonna bring a crystal skull also BFG
was not the best when we're talking
about like optimistic idealistic
adventure films fantasy films lately
spielberg is not my favorite obviously
he's an amazing director but I think
right now is not the key time to pull
him into it and when it comes to Matthew
Vaughn I would also hear say that he
doesn't want to do it I mean these took
him off seven because of creative
differences now if his creative
differences which one of which was
pitching Chloe Moretz as the lead
character who we now know is Rey
I don't know that in Episode nine I want
those creative differences to take over
I like what's happening right now with
the Star Wars universe I don't want to
go a whole new direction and my concern
that's where we'd be going I would argue
that the trailer for ready player one to
me shows Spielberg back in this crazy
epic fandom world and I did that just
kill me did that just kill me here cuz I
thought it looked amazing after it looks
like Speed Racer that's what it looks
like to me I'm not saying you're wrong
but that's the way I agree with you oh
yeah that's the show I would argue yes
the BFG and and Crystal Skull Crystal
Skull was a travesty I don't necessarily
think that and I don't think that the
fact that he said he won't do it is the
issue here for me it would be my dream
right well the Steven Spielberg Star
Wars movie because I look at things like
Raiders of the Lost Ark I look at movies
that came out around the time of the
original trilogy which is what force
awakens brought to me it was the
original trilogy again so I'm looking at
somebody who could bring that classic
adventure feel and to me the only person
that has a track record even if the last
few movies were misfires
he has decades of amazing films and I
would go with Spielberg to bring it home
and to show us how this trilogy
concludes he has said that's not my
genre I don't want to make these last
action sequence that I remember was Shaw
the buff standing between two cars going
through a siege oh I don't want anything
like that in stylism cell this is also a
way away from that stuff you got your
space battles lost a job it's a lot of
practical stuff which I'm sure he can do
but I don't think he's got like the
Spielberg that existed in 1995 is dead
and I'm sorry to say that everybody but
yes if we had a time machine and we
could bring back that Spielberg bunch of
spies interesting which is it would you
be talking on a bridge and the other
thing is the movies bill the other thing
I want to say is defense of patty
Jenkins is that she has proven time and
again that she can do touching movies
that balance multiple genres we saw
superhero romance a whole team going on
a mission anti-war moments all of that
balanced into one and Star Wars at its
heart is a genre balancing juggling it's
also the argument though that her team
was underdeveloped that the movie
basically focuses on Wonder Woman and
Steve Trevor and everybody else's kind
of background just like hey
people look at the human existence I
disagree I think the movie really fun
yeah they're fun characters but we don't
really get to know much about them it's
really Wonder Woman and Steve Trevor
story which if episode 9 was just Finn
and Rey and that's it I'm okay with that
if patty Jenkins took the reins but I
think there's a bigger world to sum up
all right final shots from all of you
but give me again why is your choice
better than the other two we'll start
with you Ben
I don't think that that Steven Spielberg
is dead as he was I think that Jurassic
Park I think Raiders of the Lost Ark I
think those are perfect films and I
think that again he has a history with
Kathleen Kennedy I think they would team
up I think Lucas is partly to blame for
her Kingdom of the Crystal Skull and I
think that this would be a return to
form for Spielberg of which he needs and
I would love to see Tricia we've seen
that patty Jenkins can do a big film
we've seen she can do amazing action
sequences she said that she would be
open to directing it since he hasn't
been brought on for Wonder Woman to yet
Star Wars films are rooted in character
and that's what patty Jenkins excels at
handle those beloved characters and make
little kids everywhere love these
characters I want to be these characters
quickly just that Matthew Vaughn can
also do a love story we've seen that he
doesn't do a lot but we know that he's
very he's more than capable of it
this also starts shooting in January and
that's something that he could turn
around like that's that's not long from
nobody if there's somebody who could do
it it's him also he took the spy films
and he made James Bond the modern James
Bond which everyone loved look boring
you can't go from Kingsman to Spectre
they're completely different he took a
ron shipp Roger Moore style Bond film
and he brought it into the modern era
and it was ridiculous and over-the-top
but it totally made sense and it works
and that than those are the only kind of
spy movies I want to see now I don't
want to see Daniel Craig running around
in a tiny little suit crying on a train
or whatever so Harry this is me was
pretty good
[Laughter]
okay gilliguy doesn't matter it's
irrelevant all right I think I have
enough there Dan yes sir hey clean up
dad you guys actually kept me busy
magic want to kick ass in 2010 excellent
first class of 2011 and then King zone
in 2014
máximo was originally attached to last
and he decided not to do it and then he
and brett ratner gonna do a little
Twitter spat about all of it
Tricia's right Steven Spielberg did say
in 2015 the Star Wars was not his genre
it's George Lucas's genre and there's
been speculation or rumor about Matthew
Vaughn that he was in talks with
Kathleen Kennedy at one point to direct
force awakens he reportedly did pitch
chloë grace moretz as the lead but
didn't progress beyond the talking phase
and they eventually settled on JJ Abrams
whom rumor also has Steven Spielberg
heavily endorsed take that part so lots
of Hollywood rumor and speculation
looking at the comments I'd say that the
fans have have a favorite but it's it's
not a run away and I looked it over that
is Andy after you're done well I can
tell you first off it's not gonna be Ben
sadly I think they both that's right I
didn't hear enough defense back on wife
spill burgers good today they sort of
did sort of his losses magical in a way
and I need it a little bit more for you
to back that up so it would came down
between Trisha and James Smith pay
Jenkins Matthew Vaughn
this was tough I mean they both would
make good movies I'm going through your
ear was sort of back and forth points
you focus on creative action sequences
redefining the genre James within Trisha
you focused on sort of making the action
and and about Ray's story and I liked
your counterpoint up she does make great
villains monster is a good point of that
you said are older films that is a very
interesting villain character man I'm
torn I think I the only reason I'm doing
is cuz I think Trisha just to give me a
little bit more of the punching down of
Spielberg harder than James did so for
your
and some other stuff I got to give it a
slight edge to Tricia based on the
counterpoint so Tricia gets the first
point but very close James Ben you'll
get there in there round two you know if
my second choice was petty Jenkins it
was in Wonder Woman is my second
favorite movie of the year so it was
very difficult - that was genuinely
tough damn where they say on the YouTube
crowd 55% backed mr. Sunday movies pic
of Matthew Vaughn 20% patty Jenkins 15%
Steven Spielberg on Twitter it's a much
closer 38 currently 38% Spielberg 236
Vaughn with patty Jenkins very close
behind at 20 the first time I'll ever
say thanks to it is ray all right here
we go from number 2 this one comes from
mr. spider clown do you know him mr.
Sunday movies with receiving rave
reviews it's doing really well um we
want to know what's the worst Stephen
King adaptation what's like of all he's
done some stinkers man and what's the
worst one Trisha Europe first okay well
as much as the wound is still deep from
Dark Tower and I wanted to say that I'm
not going with that I'm gonna go with
the Mangler um the Mangler for anyone
who hasn't seen it is this horrific film
about a possessed laundry machine no
joke it's a laundry press that decides
to attack people and it tries to chomp
people and it's the problem with this
movie is that this could be a bad good
horror film except for it's so bad it's
not even bad good like you hear
possessed laundry press at one point the
thing literally grows legs and chases
somebody like this this is just out of
this world but the CGI is so bad it's
the movie is just unwatchable it's awful
okay we'll hear more James where you
pickin for me there was a two-part it
was aired on TV first but it was two
movies out back to back in 1995 it's
called the Langille dears yeah and it's
based off a book by Stephen King of the
same name and basically it's a for those
who haven't seen it the villain is
Bronson Bronson Picoult from unchoke
Balki yes that's exactly how much
Rangers he's like a slick kind of
nineties business
he's got to get to a meeting but then
they get stuck in a time rift and then
they're transported to the day before
and they're worried because what's going
to happen over the course of four hours
is that eventually the Langille is gonna
show up and this it's the worst looking
CGI Brown golf ball you've ever seen
with like rotating razor chainsaw teeth
and they eat what's left of yesterday
and that to escape that it's really
terrible it's gonna swear but I'm not
going because there's kids watching but
imagine what I said because I mean it
CGI golf balls okay family picking I
think Maximum Overdrive because the
first 10 to 15 minutes promises me every
movie that I would ever love which is a
meteor causing radiation on planet Earth
and turning every machine against humans
and it starts off like toasters
attacking baseball machines vending
machines lawn mowers and it's like this
is gonna be incredible and then it
becomes the last hour just semi trucks
circling a gas station as people argue
inside and almost nothing happens and
for me I would rather watch something
that starts off slow and eventually
builds to something awesome then starts
off awesome and then eventually just
disappoints me and crushes my soul as to
what I thought it was going to be all
right guys fight it off wiser is the
worst why are the other ones better I
went first last time you're sure the
length of this is really long like like
I would watch either of those because
the premise isn't quite that machine
comes to life in a taxi or whatever but
at least it's 2 hours as opposed to fall
[Music]
I guess I would still I would still
stick through the languor layers again
to the first time for me would be to
find the mystery of what's gonna happen
how they're going to defeat the day
before there's a little bit of a mystery
to unravel 20 minutes into Maximum
Overdrive
you realize there's no mystery there's
no suspense you're just like cool a
Green Goblin truck is circling around
and it's scary and every once in a while
there's a cool death but not as cool as
manglers desks which are completely
insane and I would watch a walking fax
machine or of laundry machine any day
over semi trucks doing the world's worst
NASCAR race ever totally does
there is a reason that Maximum Overdrive
is a cult favorite and has a following
and it's because it's hilarious all of
the reasons that you talk about I mean
and it's got a score by ac/dc like there
are redeemable things about Maximum
Overdrive there is nothing redeemable
amount of the manglers you can have
prosthetic makeup is incredible in that
the visuals are horrible the acting is
heinous
there's not one scary moment in the
whole thing because the idea of a
laundry press that's gonna grow legs and
attack you is so bizarre there's and
then to make it a feature-length film
they add in all these weird subplots
that make no sense and aren't
interesting at all it's just a horrible
film and when I compare it against these
other two which are not great let me say
but Maximum Overdrive at least you're
dealing with again you have a score by
ac/dc there are hilarious moments killer
vending machines and arcade machines are
amazing they continue with even yourself
when you were describing it use the word
incredible that's better than a whole
movie of total crap I guess I would also
say that going into the Mangler or the
langa lairs my expectations are gonna be
lowered but hearing the premise for
Maximum Overdrive because guilty movies
are like my favorite thing and I'm like
this is gonna be the greatest thing ever
so for me I would rather see an OK film
that I had no expectations of which
would be the Mangler and the Langille
ears than something that I think is
going to be my new favorite movie ever
just poop all over it right that's what
it does it poops all over the first 10
minutes
yo tez peak 1995 Emilio Estevez money
does right one hi Mission Impossible
like the greatest actors of that
particular week yo says most Freddy
Krueger and buckle under mine has
Bronson Picoult milk it's like it's
Balki who stabs a blind girl to death
and but it said it's gay that's funny
and it's it's not it's it's not
interesting or even it's scary it's
nonsense it's just it's and it's boring
and it's also sitting mine so it's got
that aspect of Stephen King that he
can't let go it's just as a mind-reading
kid like The Shining so it's like
picking the worst things from all these
different kind of series and mashing
them in together and it does nothing for
it because it's garbage
I think the editorial I think that
Langille ears feels to me like a really
long Twilight Zone episode when you
watch an episode of Twilight Zone you're
in it for the suspense you're not
necessarily looking for the best movie
yard and I feel like the Langille ears
delivers if I'm going into it expecting
an episode of The Twilight Zone
I get what I what I was expecting I
would also argue that both of those
films have more surprises than Maximum
Overdrive because there are no surprises
just slow trucks that's it wait what
surprises did you find in the manglers
you weren't surprised that laundry press
ate the dude that that was not a suit
spoiler alert the legs that's a surprise
I didn't think it would walk off
that's a surprise for me final thoughts
Ben I just again I just I hate to keep a
hammer at home but I feel like if you
promise me something awesome and then
you deliver something disappointing I'm
more disappointed by something I think
is gonna be bad going into it and and I
think that's that's it just disappointed
me so much
Tricia final thoughts if you're acting
for if you're asking for objectively
worst movie expectations have nothing to
do with it director Toby Huber delivers
such a steaming pile of poo prosecution
in this movie ugly visuals heinous
acting no scary moments at all it's it's
just a poor movie from start to finish
nothing redeemable about it James the
Langille is is literally about monsters
from the past trapping you there and
then eating time and destroying you as a
person so you don't exist anymore
which is what the movie feels like when
you watch it Dan yeah the lincoler I
started the Mangler Mangler lengthens
the Mangler was based on a Stephen King
short story was directed a co-written by
tobe Hooper a great horror director who
passed away recently he also did Salem's
Lot
which is a Stephen King book I believe
Bronson Pinchot was in the leg Lear's
well also in the Llangollen al for my
evil from quantum leap Stephen King
himself was the only girl ears as long
as the director who will now be referred
to as the Tom Holland that is not
spider-man tom hollie directing clears
that spidery Maximum Overdrive Stephen
King wrote and directed it came out in
1986 not 1995 Mighty Ducks came out in
1992 but we're still at peak Estevez
I'll give you and the Mangler was
followed by two sequels the Mangler 2
and the Mangler reborn my life is in the
Mangler reborn so just to be clear she
gets murdered in it by getting a clearly
foam hammer to the head and dragged off
and it was good enough for two sequels
[Music]
ultimately I think it did come down to
both Tricia and been sort of told me
things that sounded kind of fun which
James were two pointed out even watching
Robert Englund is more fun in you and as
Tricia said admitted you love the first
six but gee and I couldn't really hear
anything aside from yeah well there's a
long Twilight Zone episode and there's a
mystery I think James is a very good job
explaining why the language is four
hours of just nothing but bad mash
Stephen King moments with nothing really
a positive out of it so I got to give
James for that reason the play it's a
rare thing but all of the socials are an
agreement 48% of on Twitter and a
whopping 50 are sorry 69% on YouTube
agree that the L'Engle ears is worst
it's really bad too but with this
question I realized how few Stephen King
adaptations I've seen of the bad ones
yeah there's a lot of bad one the tram
what else did they suggest one more man
sucking us off some people said
lawnmower man a lot of a lot of people
said dreamcatcher which is one of the
strangest weirdest most bizarre movies
there were some people saying like does
langu leaders count because it's a TV
yeah yes we sent the show accounts and
always counts the Tommyknockers really a
lot of his to was the whole ABC run with
after in SHINee I was one of the stand
was one that one stink now why does a
lot for TV but yeah I'd say that the
Lego leaders was one that was cited
often but dream catcher I think though
I'm not in this group was one that was
very good cemetery - does that count cuz
that was really not based off of
directly off a Stephen King more
characters sort of characters yeah but
Dark Tower broke my heart
yeah Dark Tower was one see it yeah
anyway dinner that was really bad
there's not right alright here we go
question three guys since China Lyubov
is not returning for Indiana Jones
that's the what they've said we want you
to pitch a totally new sidekick for Indy
in his next adventure so let's have some
fun here James you get to start us off
describe who your character is and who
would play your character in the next
Indiana Jones Adventure right I'm gonna
roll the dice on this I feel like this
is gonna bite me in the ass but I feel
so passionately about this that I'm just
gonna go with it
grace is a returning character that we
haven't seen since Temple of Doom and
what I'm proposing is that instead of
bringing somebody in you just being like
oh look he's also got a daughter and she
gets his hat whatever they are doing
what they could do is bring back an
adult short round Nathan Drake esque
hero who they had some kind of parting
of ways because he's been dragging this
small Asian boy to foreign countries to
be heavies heart torn out and all the
other adventures that they went on like
bugs and all sorts of spiders and [ __ ]
but now he's gone and done his own thing
and then they have to come back together
to work on it to work on a new adventure
even though they're estranged so they're
kind of like father and son you got that
element but you've also got the the
aspect of bringing back something fun
from the past and reinventing it and you
cast someone like a Stephen no unit from
The Walking Dead he could easily fill
that role he's got a profile that's big
enough for it and also he could carry a
franchise on from that or a spin-off in
a way that like Shia LaBeouf shallow
buffer couldn't Wow all right
ballsy picked there'd been what are you
doing I would say that I think they
really messed up and for the opportunity
to have any sort of fatherly
relationship and one of my favorite
sidekicks in the series with Sean
Connery and the father-son dynamic I
don't want to do a father-son thing cuz
Shia LaBeouf ruin that but I think a
daughter would be interesting I think
that a lot of these franchises are going
for a more strong female leads and I
obviously not getting somebody like a
Daisy Ridley but maybe a mary elizabeth
winstead or something to play his
younger daughter who he then has to he
always does really well with strong
women and there's that fun comedic twist
to it that is a little less racist and I
think it could be a fun dynamic for him
to be faced up against a very strong
female who happens to be his daughter so
he has to parent her but also go on
adventures with her which I would love
because that's what I loved about Last
Crusade
all right Trisha um okay I'm super
excited for this one I feel like we need
someone innocent to play off of how
jaded Indiana has become someone who's
relatable to the audience so Indiana
Jones has a reason to deliver his
methods in an organic way to the
audience and for this reason I think
that we are going to have Marcus's
grandson come into the picture so Marcus
has passed away but his grandson angle
Bert Marcus Brody the third to which we
find out that Marcus is real first name
was Henkel Bert Oh obviously has
inherited his fortune and decides that
he now wants to fund Indiana's next
adventure so there's a reason for this
pairing we know why he's teamed up with
him um and I would cast I'm gonna say
his name wrong but Gatton Matarazzo from
stranger things funny kid from stranger
things they're all funny
which one curly yeah that's Ivana Cass
isn't she's hilarious both in his
on-screen and off-screen antics so I
think he could absolutely deliver the
comedy that we'd need and I just I love
this storyline of Indy having to be
paired with someone it that's a
reluctant sidekick and it's because he
needs the funds in his old age to go on
this next archeological adventure I
think it sets it up perfectly and
because they've already established that
Marcus is no longer with us it's a nice
way to pay respects to that character as
well okay guys find out I would say that
the issue with with shortround is that
the client the question was was it's a
totally new character he's existed said
that already
cancels that out for me the issue with I
actually liked where you're going until
you said basically an 11-year old kid
and to me that that totally like Jar Jar
Binks is the situation where
then suddenly it's playing way more like
an Iron Man 3 type funny kid
relationship and to me I think that that
would then kind of bring the whole movie
down again and we'd have a Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull a relationship all
over again unless he's not a 12 year old
kid nor was that the situation in
Crystal Skull um you would be more
closely if you're saying I don't like
his dynamic with a kid talking about
Temple of Doom which I think universally
everyone can agree was a really great
movie with very funny moments that
people remember now my problem with
bringing shortround back now it's all of
the humor around short run was basically
one big racist joke how do you bring
back the nostalgia from that without
just going that route but now in a more
PC culture well you weren't it and you
cost somebody likes Steven Yeun so he
doesn't turn up you know for lack of a
better word doing yellow-faced he plays
the kind of person that he is he's a
hero he's not some Asian stereotype
he's the thing that the forefront of the
character would be he's a guy he's not a
stereotype he's a God and I think what
the other characters are with we've seen
in like diehard they've gone oh John
McClane's got a daughter oh and John
McClane's got a son okay who cares
neither of those could also carry that
franchises as was as was indicated and I
don't know yet kids in movies know
and who's gonna kids gonna take are they
gonna take down the man to live in you
know you guys are both pitching people
that you want to take on the mantle I
don't want anyone else to take on the
mantle because they're not gonna be
another Harrison Ford make make indiana
jones like a James Bond where we cast
different iterations of them but not
like a Batman Robin where we're handing
off the cape to somebody else to then
continue the series I think that that in
and of itself is a bad direction to go
with Indiana I mean I think just because
we're setting examples of where
father/daughter father-son relationships
have been done wrong doesn't mean that
inherently they're going to do this
wrong I think that the way that Ray may
be Luke's daughter who knows we I think
that you can have Indiana Jones having a
daughter and right the wrongs of Kingdom
of Crystal Skull and to me I think a
strong female would be a great foil to
Indiana Jones just like in Raiders of
Lost Ark and to
then you can also you basically get to
combine the dynamic of Raiders of the
Lost Ark with Last Crusade because you
have the father-daughter and the
male/female to me that's the perfect
combination of comedy and adventure that
makes sense that doesn't make it sort of
a kids movie and doesn't make it a
return of a character that already
existed which cancels a question I don't
think because you're saying you're
casting a younger after that it makes it
a kids movie with stranger things a kids
TV series no it absolutely was not and
we're always talking about this being
like a Jar Jar Binks character that
actor is I want to say 16 now so it's
not like he's this little 8 year old
that's gonna be running around behind
him he can present a wonderful sidekick
and I'm sorry but I just saw Crystal
Skull most recently surprised you're my
dad whether it's with a girl it's
swapping the gender if that doesn't make
that any better for me I'm still burned
from crystal skull I don't want to see
that again and who's gonna be his lover
this time that just pops up out of the
woodwork you know like it I just I don't
see where that's going
burn me once please don't burn me again
let's go an entirely different direction
with this next one using as your final
thoughts James final thoughts ok right
so the Indiana Jones psychic stiphu
consisted of a lady a small Asian boy a
Nazi lady and Shia LaBeouf right this
this isn't Bernie's dad I guess this is
an equal somebody who he can pair off
with in the way that Jai Courtney and
Bruce Willis should have in die hard
they can bounce off each other from
different generations have got different
different opinions but they also know
each other
he knows Indiana Jones inside out and
that's a really interesting dynamic to
me not somebody who just shows up he's
like hey I'm a kid oh hey I'm your
daughter this is somebody who has USA
who he has a history with a really
interesting history who probably hates
him because he's a bad bloke I just I
really really would love to see a strong
female go with Indiana Jones on an
adventure and I think that I think that
you can right the wrongs of we should
just erase kingdom of Crystal Skull and
to me that would be a great way to do it
is hitting the reset button having a
really touching relationship I think
that would be the one with the most
emotional impact as well I don't think a
Richie Rich grandson that's a goofball
would do it and I don't think a
character who's already existed counts
for the question that's
[Laughter]
dan yes well I stated on the show many
times if it's accepted as an answer
accountable yeah really I was just going
into in deal or over here there is
expanded lore I was reading about short
round there's a couple of other
adventures of Indiana Jones that
establishes that short round was went to
boarding school and then came out and
helped Indy in the 30s and then there's
a journal tie-in to Crystal Skull said
he was out doing stuff in the 50s so
short rounds kicking around out there
somewhere
who knows where yeah Gaytan matarazzo I
believe that say he pronounced his name
is it's about 14 15 right now so almost
15 actually tomorrow's your market at
the dates on my watch his birthday is
actually tomorrow so he's 15 years old
tomorrow sure there you go it's the
others of that I'm looking at the polls
I'd say that there's a fan favorite but
I don't want to tip the scale so I'll
let you know what it is after you
alright well I might need help let's see
I mean I think I do want a strong female
lead but I think they dinged you on the
daughter part I think if you just
created an original female lead that
probably helped but who's who's the
lover surprise you're my dad again I
think is giving us a little bit of a bad
flashbacks if you do yeah and then it
came down tsukemono Tricia and James
strangely the adults shortround if I
thought you were up against the wall
there but these sort of would by saying
you own it and he's actually a person
now and they have a history and you hate
him like it's kind of something
interesting about that because you can
play up like you were a racist to me you
can actually maybe drive a car like you
were a terrible person like and then you
know there's something fun there for
sure and then you Tricia you gave me a
good back story to reluctant sidekick is
key I think I got just for the sake of
being ballsy I got to give James the
point you you owned it and then you sold
me somehow I didn't think you were gonna
so fat surprised I got to give a short
adult short round
technically we would get a new character
because we've never seen it don't screw
around
dan when they say online 72% of the
YouTube audience voted for adult
shortround 53% of the Twitter audience
so a lot of fans support for bringing
back adults short round to the other day
strangely I mean when you watch that to
men I would they did it right yeah yes
that's a nice photo like oh yeah that
was bad I like that I know I argue
something I like and agree with but I
feel like that should be like that the
subtitle of movie there's a lot of
hashtag bad bloke happening all right
here we go round four and this one comes
from yeast Lewis used to do this six to
five sorry things said that wrong gets
to do us we want a silly one
this was actually this was a good one
because of this tweet I this thought was
so good we adjusted slightly but the
question is sorry I'll just spit it out
what's the best movie to watch with
commentary from the director but I was
made sure they're sitting next to you so
if you had to watch a movie what could
you have the opportunity to watch a
movie with a director sitting right next
to you in the couch you could pause
asking things her things whatever you
want who would be the most interesting
director to sit next to you Ben we're
back to you start first
for me it's Kevin Smith with Mallrats
because the interesting dynamic of going
from a 35,000 dollar movie that you
funded on your credit cards to a studio
film where you have little control and
the drama that went on behind it and the
hilarity that went on behind it plus
just listening to him talk you can tell
a 25-minute story about Prince and it's
hysterical so I have a feeling it would
be a seven-hour experience of us smoking
a lot of pot and pausing in the movie
constantly but it would be hilarious and
I would get some really good dirt on the
movie and the behind the scenes which I
would love okay
Trisha I'm probably the underdog in this
fight but I went with what we do in the
shadows and taiko Aditi I think that
that is a hilarious film and if I'm
going to watch any movie with
in Terry I want it to feel like a
Mystery Science Theater he's a hilarious
individual and so I want to hear what he
has to say so much of that film was
improv from what I understand that I
would love to just hear the stories from
one set of what they were intending to
do with that scene or what kind of just
happened in the moment and they decided
to keep it from a person who loves
hearing stories about what happened on
set between the actors I feel like this
is this is would be a dream come true
all right James right if we talk about
things that we want to know what
happened on set i picked Fantastic Four
from 2015 because that movie is an
absolute train wreck and we have very
little idea of what actually happened if
you got Josh Trank in a room by himself
and you said look this is off the books
why don't you tell me exactly what
happened here
you could take you through the same by
scene and be like yeah I shot that and I
didn't shoot that yeah this that's the
actual moment I got fired oh yeah this
is the part where I me and
what's-his-face gotten a punch up or
whatever because I'd apparently happened
human miles teller so I don't know all
that that's a [ __ ] film the story behind
that film is incredible probably okay
again small rats with Kevin Smith you
can already see Kevin Smith's commentary
on everything like a million times over
it's out there so if you have one wish
to kind of teleport a director onto the
couch next to you I wouldn't choose
someone that I could find their
commentary for free on YouTube already
okay that would be my argument against
Kevin Smith and against Josh Trank I
would love to say do I want to find out
what he would have done with the film if
given better resources yes does that
make me want to watch that awful movie
again no if it was just a conversation
or an interview with him a hundred
percent yes but if I still have to watch
the movie I'm out I agree if I have to
watch the movie done but also I think
josh trank it would just be depressing
because he went from doing Chronicle and
thinking he's on top of the world he
like I mean he almost Troy defeat
himself but I don't think anybody's
tried to feed themselves from Boondock
Saints but josh trank to me would just
be a depressing watch and the movies
depressing already what we do in the
shadows is great an improv but I can't
imagine that the commentary would be
more than just like I think we were
gonna do this funny thing yeah and this
funny thing and that was pretty funny
and that was pretty funny but for me
I would love to know more dirt on
shannen doherty and how she was kind of
a B word onset I would love to know how
many times Jason Mewes was almost fired
and replaced by Seth Green I know that
Kevin Smith has limitless commentary out
there and it's all hysterical I've never
been sitting next to him on a couch
getting to experience it firsthand the
hilarity and ask him anything I want
about one of my favorite comedies I
think it would be incredible in the fact
that he had to fight for it I would love
to know who the unnamed actor is that
was supposed to be cast as Brody and I
don't maybe it's out there I don't know
but that got fired after the first day
when he broke down on set there's the
drama that you get from josh trank and
the hilarity you get from what we do in
the shadows from a well known person
who's hysterical that could then be my
best friend I think you just want the
contact hi George I don't actually smoke
pot but I imagine I would in that
instance you don't you don't want to
deal with him this happened and that was
pretty funny and this happened to no is
pretty funny that could be said of Kevin
Smith with Mallrats as well so I don't
feel like that story right would be
things I would be looking for from Taika
Waititi is how they came up with those
ridiculous characters in the first place
like how were they sitting there and
said oh you know what I'm gonna be the
room at the roommate that's OCD about
scheduling but also a vampire and also
this is my backstory there's lots to be
gained they're more than just funny
things that happen on that but do I
think there's a million hours of
commentary and funny things that happen
on set there has to be it was an improv
to film we're we're werewolves knots
werewolves
we're God thing I think that uh both of
these guys are open books in terms of
what they produce Kevin Smith would talk
about more rats in an empty room for
four hours like without a doubt and
there's nothing wrong with that but
anything you want to know about that
film you could probably find out already
and it's the same take awhile TD and
what we do in the shadows that's an
amazing film I just want to watch that
film I don't want to sit there any guys
it's pretty good what do you think about
this one's pretty funny his commentary
so lame in your body funny it was just
going to sound like yeah what I think
give me a tiger with TD impression there
so we first got together and thought
about these characters and we're just it
may be over a game of D&D we were all
playing and
camera playing vampire the masquerade we
were like what would these guys be like
if they were hanging out now and how
would that happen and what would their
interactions with werewolves be and this
is how we came up with this idea and
then also in the moment when he was
doing this sexy strip dance he just
decided to do this you know and they
kept it and but that kind of stuff
that's what I wanted okay got it
no I keep going G I wanted it because
you call her I was trying to I just I
just don't think it's that interesting a
story I I genuinely don't I think it's a
funny film and he's he's taken all the
elements I'm sure they did a lot of
different takes and whatever but
somebody explaining a funny moment that
happened in a film that they cut out cuz
it wasn't as funny as a moment they left
in isn't as good as watching the movie
with the funniest parts because they put
it in the movie because it's a comedy in
that sound movies work ready for finding
out how the funniest parts that were
kept in the film came to be is
fascinating and if you loved that movie
and you want to know how that came about
then that's awesome alright I just want
to end everything with movie types rules
like Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure or
something alright Dan oh yeah a lot of
people just pitching directors like
David Lynch Quentin Tarantino any of
their movies that they would like to sit
down and watch Michael ikenson says it'd
be fascinating to watch Armageddon with
Michael Bay I want oh so badly for him
to explain that film to me is already
pretty great
Michael Joel Schumacher for Batman and
Robin came up a lot of Parker and Stone
South Park basketball but kind of all
over the place no real consensus as far
as one that everyone seems to want to
see and looking at the poll it seems
like it's a pretty tight contest as well
no all right
yeah I mean I think I wasn't sold Trisha
on what we're gonna learn I mean yeah I
think both James and Ben sort of hit I
agreed with their Pitman's hits of you
of just like we're gonna learn some of
the stuff that wasn't as funny stuff
that was in there and the movies pretty
funny that said you did have a really
good shot you hit it up first of a week
also against Ben we have seen Kevin
Smith talk about this movie for hours on
end you can find it on YouTube all over
the place any or any of his get together
it's done a lot you also pointed out
that what started that if we don't
really want to watch Fantastic Four
again which goes against you James of
that would suck to sort of watch and
Bend your credit also it probably would
be depressing
interesting though yeah so while I would
love to I could take my personal opinion
out of what I would want to watch based
on the arguments I wasn't with Ben but
you sort of sold me on the experience of
yeah let's just get high and actually
find this social story that he hasn't
revealed and let's get those
commentaries maybe he'll be my friend
afterwards
come on is your impression of that
watching what we do the shadows is yeah
that was funny it wouldn't be very good
either I agree so I'm gonna get because
I was interested in James's pitch and I
agree like it would probably be very
depressing personally chosen that yeah
forty six percent of the YouTube
audience forty four percent of the
Twitter audience she chose Fantastic
Four and let me add my voice to that
because I would give anything to sit
down with Josh Trank and go over that
movie anytime a new josh trank okay I
want you to be tried and we've tried we
tried please do that should I come into
your less but it was that thirty percent
said Kevin Smith and Taika Waititi on
Twitter and it's about the same on
YouTube so yeah I would private very
close but good choice Ben you're still
in it as long as I don't go in the pity
point is while you're in that point
under six a it was but it wasn't I'm
excited I didn't get a what go away a
victim of a flawless victory no no I
think it's fun to hang out with Kevin
listen I'm talking you'll get some
stories he's not don't contact hi so
there's a bonus that's why I'm legacy
was so good when I saw I stuck out a
contact high right question five this
one comes in from
photo ninja 91 aka amber Harris Thank
You amber
I thought this was a funny question what
movie would be better on mute what movie
you have to turn off the sound and you
can only watch it can't hear it what
movie would benefit from that Trisha
what are you pickin okay I picked the
island I when I'm thinking of what movie
I want to watch on mute I'm trying to
look for something that is visually fun
to watch that has good acting
performances from the faces of the
actors even if the dialogue and the plot
are lacking so that to me is a perfect
description of the film the island
alright great visuals I agree
let's see James are you pickin I chose
children of men which although it's a
very cerebral story in terms of you know
the story it's actually it's when you
turn the sound up that movie in follows
involved in a completely different way
you release I kind of this bleak future
you don't really know what's going on
it's kinda it's all kind of run down
everybody's sad like it's like a Josh
Trank s kind of feeling kind of open
everything and then journey survivors
like that yeah and oculus so it's also
good to watch and then all of a sudden
is to reveal that there's a woman in
this in this universe who's pregnant and
then when you go wait a minute you think
back there's no kids in that movie
leading up there's like billboards of
people adopting dogs and you're like oh
well that makes sense because there were
no kids in this universe and and all of
a sudden you've got this new element of
a twist but only exists if you watch it
on you cool okay okay then I'd say I
transformers three because Michael Bay
movies are arguably technically very
well made but they lack it is just as
the island they lack in plot they lack
in there's a joke parade that is not
funny
there's transformers you begin three
Dark Gaia because there's incredible
actors in it there's Stanley Tucci
there's alan tudyk there's Ken Jong's
hilarious there's John Turturro this
Frances McDorman there's and they're all
doing good performances with just
terrible dialogue and the action scenes
when they do kick in are technically
amazing and awesome to watch the Chicago
battle in the end with shockwaves worm
attacking the skyscraper is incredible
and to me if you muted that the action
is still all good but then I can just
make up the jokes that these great
actors are saying and it'll be hilarious
because there's some good
gags just a parade of awful juvenile
humor that I can make up funny stuff
instead and it would enhance the
experience all right guys
fight it out Rock Paper Scissors go
okay I'm gonna go um I feel like for
children of men when you take out the
dialog and the fly you're taking out
wonderful things about that film like
that's the one in Oscar for Best Writing
why would you watch it on mute I feel
like I'm doing yourself a disservice
your pinch was explaining how you could
still find out what the conflict was on
mute but that's like saying well I mean
I have to go to this I have to go to
this party but I have to go in a
wheelchair but here's how I could still
do it you're explaining how to get past
an obstacle that you self-imposed at
that point not necessarily a movie
that's better on mute and then I would
say when it comes to transformers 3 that
movie is still not salvageable just by
eliminating the dialogue and the fly no
there's uninteresting characters there's
dull performances visually poor framing
and a lot of the sequences of special
effects don't even make sense together
wingsuits wingsuits yes I don't know
whether that's good or bad but wing says
maybe the only redeeming things about
transformers 3 are the sound mixing and
sound editing which it was nominated for
an Oscar for both of those things and
you're taking those away when you put it
on but I'm also taking away the endless
amount of terrible jokes and what I
would say about children of men is it's
a near-perfect film I love children of
men it was nominated for three Oscars I
agree that you could still figure it out
like a silent film but I think it does
detract from the experience not hearing
the dialogue I would say that the island
is a much better premise than
transformers 3 in a much better film
therefore it doesn't need to be on mute
I say transformers needs to be on mute
to be a better movie the island can
still be enjoyed as a chase film there's
a lot of cool stuff going on with the
fact that they're on this weird
dystopian Island and then they find out
that they're basically just giant organ
harvesting organ donors
idea and that wouldn't necessarily all
make sense on mute
transformers makes no sense with the
volume on and so it'll make just as
little sense with the volume off but
maybe more cuz I can have fun making up
with the jokes it's AI what I'm saying
is transformers is the worst movie of
the three that's why I'm mute would
enhance it cuz the visuals when they're
fighting in the freeway chase is
unbelievable it's just unbelievably bad
otherwise I would say you probably
haven't watched the island recently
because it completely falls apart in the
second half yes the premise when you set
it up at first is cool and I think that
you would get that even on mute because
of the interesting lighting and the
interesting costumes and the set design
all of these things that are still
perfectly intact when watching the film
on mute you still get Scarlett Johansson
and you and MacGregor emoting through
their face as they do super well but you
lose the part which is the only poor
part of the film which is where the plot
completely falls apart at the end and
there are these amazing action sequences
in the island as well so I would go
toe-to-toe with you there on
transformers 3 I think that arguably
though that the action sequences in the
island aren't near as spectacular and
bombastic and huge and crazy as all of
Chicago being destroyed and basically
the Autobots doing a full-on apocalyptic
wasteland battle with the Decepticons
and then gangster shooting the the old
robot totally Tony Tony Soprano style I
think that there's some awesome visuals
where as you're telling me that the
third act over the island falls off
visually so that it doesn't fall off
visually that's what I'm saying it's so
beautiful visually I've got more
explosions it falls off because of the
plot which again when we watch it on you
that's okay but if you watch names
inning around look I just think at the
end of the day they're both really
boring movies you're also slightly less
boring regardless of whether they are
mute or not or not I don't want to watch
them children is a different element it
not it has beautiful visuals and
beautiful people not as golden but they
exist there in the universe are much
more
but it's a more interesting film all
right as we wrap this up and your
closing can you act out in in without
any dialogue what your movie would be
like to sell me yeah right now yeah
no sounds okay mute mute the mic sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry you got excited
I'm like need it again him yeah lift it
alright I'm gonna watch the TV re
treasure your wedding I'm gonna meet
your mic and I'm gonna watch you watch
the right here's the island on you oh
wow wow she got okay Wow guns okay
alright James your turn yep here we go
children men on mute here we go whoa
calves real deep real dark
alright that did help me alright I got
enough dad everything bad just a couple
of some people watching at home too but
still good answers a mum be Henry said
the artist sorry young mute and this was
a great Jason Dolan I like this answer
Jason Belet said Amelie because you
could read the subtitles works a good
worker on strim I'm proud of many of our
viewers
outside of the box and no one thought of
a subtitle optional one quick close
caption could also work one quick
correction children that was nominated
for another factory fleet did not win
the Oscar well I'm glad you brought that
because to me that was the ceiling of
the Fate for me you cut out the best
writing and you cut out the sound mixing
and editing which are two crucial parts
of your movie Ben and then the writing
is a wonderful story to be told so
Trisha sold me on the island it's just a
pretty people running around doing
stupid stuff so why not take the sound
off good research but they are even part
three they were a member we were talking
about that the Transformers franchise
has a lot of Oscar nominations because
of sound mixing editing etc hi Dan what
were they saying online 57% of our
Twitter audience said transformers 3 47%
Thank You YouTube audience said
transformers 3 so it was ok no I can
sense this audience picked but as always
based on argument they so do all right
well ban that you did fabulous now
you're gonna help me judge here because
James and Trisha will move into the
speed round and relieve the speed rail
really really really stress works James
you will have 20 seconds ok I'll use our
quick answers you if you both say the
same answer at the same time it's
whoever said it first
so ever so at first we'll get that
answer you have to pick a second answer
quickly
now you'll have 20 seconds for your
first round by yourself and then you'll
each have 22 sorry 10 second rebuttals
will go through this as we go so it'll
make sense and how far behind them I
you're tied I'll walk you through
question one I'm going to ask a broad
question here tell me the answer as
quickly as you can and then I'll tell
you what you have to do afterwards but
don't argue yet but pick your answer
here we go question 1
in honor of mother best darren aronofsky
movie
darn girl I'm speed round brain farting
right now I'm sorry
it happens pick one then I'll give five
more seconds if someone can pull it
you'll get the point
alright we're gonna do a new question
we'll save that from their time for a
dream all right let's try again
here we go who'd make a better Star Wars
film I'm gonna give you two choices one
quickly who would make the better Star
Wars film David Lynch or Wes Anderson so
you're gonna have David Lynch coming off
of Twin Peaks right yeah there we go and
Wes Anderson coming off of uh isn't he
working on some pet hotel movie or
something I'm just giving you a minute
to think about that sorry I was stalling
for both of you all right James you have
Wes Anderson first when everybody was
Anderson is an amazing storyteller so
stabbed Finch but also he's it's
visually compelling you know it's a
movie that specifically my just talking
about my own film what can I rebuttal
yet sorry I'm gonna be clear I'll give
you he'll take a couple seconds out you
have 20 seconds to do it all okay
excellent you ready so you he'll add a
couple more David Leitch had the
opportunity to do return the Jedi in
1983 and you chose not to because it
gave him a migraine so he doesn't want
to do it if he did it would be terrible
because he hates it it's a grueling on
purpose which it kind of be great all
right 20 seconds why would Wes Anderson
make a better Star Wars film and David
Lynch oh no I'm sorry David Lynch why
would you make it better I guess okay um
I would say that in your past you want
to overcome things that your are things
that are kind of knocks your career and
turning down Star Wars I would say is a
huge knock to your career so coming off
twin Pink's I feel like this is the time
to say yes not this doesn't give me a
migraine I can handle this and I can do
it and I can do it proud and this can be
a huge mark in my career moving forward
ten seconds James he absolutely wouldn't
do it yeah he just wouldn't I wish I'd
missing Mike because he's like that's
weird only something we because I'm
crazy easy and I think it could be weird
crazy in a good way potentially good
he's not doing a job I'm gonna come to
you first because that was tough yeah
but for me it came down to do I buy the
argument that David Lynch would what I
would regard not doing stars is a
mistake and yeah fixes careers probably
pretty happy with who cares and Wes
Anderson is weird and crazy so i
thoughts based on their arguments just
that Wes Anderson who was brought up his
visual style and I and I know that you
probably were thinking of David Lynch's
visual style but I didn't hear anything
about the pitch on how what he would do
differently or what he would do other
than just correcting a mistake in his
career all right so where James gets the
first point all right here we go number
four here we go
I'm screening the number for the
listener this is number two I am number
four do we cut the first question
because I didn't get it we never
established that rule we should make a
make that clear do they go all right
what what film features the best ever
gary oldman performance what film
features the best ever gary oldman
performance Stoker's Dracula that's not
true
oh man another interest think of a Gary
Oldman performance that you love so bad
it's my brother watching I can't
oh she's it happens in her lights I
totally get it I've been there myself
this is my mo I always pray always
losing speed around all right well I
gotta give James that first point so
he's in it okay try your winter dress
hey I just want to hear it ladies
genuinely think look it's a weird movie
but it is kind of an amazing captivating
performance
I mean Keanu Reeves is in that movie and
he does a terrible performance Gary
Oldman does something completely at ease
we at wheelhouse for that time time or
even since except you count like Fifth
Element I guess I gotta stop it on that
but I just think it's a really
interesting performance and that's what
people remember from that movie even
I'll smoke cry
screaming into your brain I was like
romance all right Trish you go watch
some more Gary or you know what happens
all right here we go guys you're still
in it I think you have to get this
though yeah okay
we've had bad moms fat Santa bad grandpa
what other bad person should join the
franchise what bad movie do we want to
see bad what this is a creative answer
bad karate instructor I'm gonna go with
uh bad nannies Oh pulled that out yeah
bad karate instructors jamjam first okay
do you remember the scene in the new
Karate Kid raybert where Jackie Chan
baits out 12 10 year olds it would be
that but it'd be two hours and I think
that would be incredible that's how he's
proven to me oh that's seen in sign from
what Kramer goes to the class and it's
all little kids and he's just karate
chopping it in the neck but then I turn
the tides and they beat the [ __ ] out of
him so it goes both ways you get what
you want whoever you want to say get
bait up all right
Trisha I'm looking at old sweet Mary
Poppins like ladies that come to the
house and just have all the answers but
as soon as they're off shift all they do
is get together throw back a bunch of
drinks and talk about the ridiculously
creepy stuff that they do to keep these
kids in line so that they can have a
good day and go outside and have a smoke
bad nanny oh all right I'll say you're
both on into both of these so you got to
sell me in your ten seconds here go
ahead I mean look violence is hilarious
obviously but I feel like we've seen bad
nannies we've seen bad moms that's what
bad moans is oh we're just gonna chop
with our kids off where everyone were
gonna go and look we're drinking like
crazy we're in a supermarket slow-motion
walk down the aisle who cares
nannies are supposed to be the better
caretaker there they're the ones that
have all the answers the super nanny
it's not Super Mom it's super nanny and
we've seen karate instructors that
weren't quite so switch all right Ben
based on those arguments I don't know
because arguably mrs. Doubtfire although
a good nanny was lying to the children
the whole time you didn't say that
though and and yeah yeah and foot fists
way is a bad karate instrument done yeah
it's tough because they both been done
in a way huh I mean he wasn't really a
nanny he was a terrible father
I'm really torn on this one because I do
agree that the slow motion like we're
supposed to be good that I liked I don't
know but then the karate instructor has
been done too so I don't know I'm torn I
can't help tan I'm useless I was so
unsure she sighed like the fern initial
pitches I'm like I thought it was better
however what James said that's kind of
what bad moms was it was like we're
getting rid of the kids and we're going
out and having drinks that's kind of
true and so I actually found myself
swinging a little bit more to James cuz
I'm the rebuttal because I thought he
brought up a good point of like we've
already kind of seen that I don't know I
well I'm gonna help here and I agree
because I think I was fun and I was with
you like you missed the opportunity of
like they should have been ragging on
the parents more
[Music]
because the parents are the terrible
people and out of you that's trigger out
ways to spin it there so now I've been
funny right and he called out that we've
sort of seen it at the same time though
is violence fun no that's pretty much
well Bravo mr. Sunday movies himself
I'm so happy you finally got to do this
I hope we can help you come back cuz
that was a blast you want to hang out
with you and have you so thank you for
coming James tell us what we get where
they can find you I don't already know
I'm sure they do but maybe potentially I
have a youtube channel called Mesa Sun
in movies it's fine it's time Twitter
handle but I've got a podcast called the
weekly planner where we talk movies and
comics and TV shows with my friend Nick
Mason it's a lot of fun it's just it's
just nonsense but it kind of in a good
way I also have a podcast network that I
started with my wife Claire
it's called planet Broadcasting and it's
got a whole other show is including like
comedy and this start was one there's
human interest that if you if you can
think of a thing you like that it might
be on there dude I'll get you and Nick
back some time yeah that's - it was
let's make sure it doesn't happen as
long I waited waited cuz now the fans
are gonna want you back immediately
we're talking about maybe you guys could
come to a striping Australians down
there
I will bring Alisha right like that all
right and that trisha hershberger Bravo
thank you will you brought something you
brought the power and and the facts
there so thank you for bringing anything
you'd like to plug yes absolutely I have
a new show on Facebook as part of
Facebook's new launch content it's
called bits and bytes it's all about
video games and it airs every Friday at
noon you can find that on Facebook if
you go to at bits and bytes show and
then fights BY tes you can also find me
on geek and sundry's twitch every
Tuesday at 4:00 talking all the video
game news stuff on game engine suite go
check her out and give her support and
then Ben Ben Bagley welcome back
anything you'd like to plug oh yeah yeah
sure you can find me tad the Ben Begley
I do a podcast every week called guilty
movie pleasures we're at guilty movie
guys with my buddy Jesse McIntosh he's
hilarious and awesome and my wife and I
are starting soon so you can follow us
and I promise funny stuff will be coming
on at parents vs. baby we're starting a
big parent comedy brand that were or by
big I mean we're still working on it but
it's gonna be it's gonna be very funny
and so that parents vs. baby no pressure
yeah no pressure no pressure it has to
be hilarious and funny and funny then
Murr on the couch dad no no good show
fun show a lot of people are happy to
see James here and enjoyed the show
overall so plummet thanks for watching
thank you for watching thank you at home
for watching as always we will see you
next week I'm Andy signorine Signori
Twitter and such and we'll see you next
week again live here as always from
Hollywood 4 p.m. Pacific Standard Time
Thursdays for another move fights happy
wonderful weekend bye bye bye
thanks again to t-mobile for sponsoring
today's episode check out what makes
them America's best unlimited network at
t-mobile comm slash coverage
[Music]
you